ein notar ex du bist ein notar
glückwunsch sehr guter name oder was
geht hier ist ghani und heute spielen
wir eine runde games und zwar ganz
klassisch was beide gruppen weil ich
hier oben da das so schön sehe sowie
games vier meine all time favorite karte
und ja ich dachte mir einfach wenn ich
mal wieder was aufnehmen weil die
letzten tag meiner viele blogs bzw auch
einmal nichts dachte ich mir ich mal
wieder so ein oldtimer classic und zwar
hier soweit wieder ins team
das reimt sich sogar deshalb haue ich
euch so ja ich bin ziemlich
durchschnittlich gerade fest aber ich
habe nicht mehr so viel zeit und bett
jetzt deshalb diese runde möglichst lol
lol da ist letzten markt da vorne ist ja
cool oder erst letzten metern
wenn der letzte ice dann ist ein richtig
cooler ja wie ich ihn gehasst wie ich
ihn vermisst habe diesen dreckigen
survival games pack das sein ganzer
verfechter lud aus seinem perfekten
inventar verschwindet grüße an den typen
der das letzte mal meinte dass das ich
doch meine vorbildfunktion wahrnehmen
würde weil ich so oft fluche glaub so
was gibt's hier feiert es gibt ja auf
jeden fall leute die die nehmen die noch
weniger war als ich die vorbildfunktion
kann man durchaus sagen behaupte ich
jetzt einfach mal weil ich probiere mich
zumindest keine falschen vorstellungen
wert oder sowas da gebe ich auch drauf
kaka vermittelt aber ich bin selbst
vorgehe kauft ganz viele drogen was ich
bin durch meine freunde ich bin ich hab
kein geld mehr auf der bank
schauen wir mal dass wir etwas gewinnen
ich kann ich dann eine scheiße labern
wenigstens dadurch ausgleichen
ja ich habe auf jeden fall gleich noch
mal schick nachhilfe weil beschreiben am
dienstag klausur und ich hab so schießt
und übrigens habe ich morgen geburtstag
werde 18 jahre alt endlich ich ja was
man halt sein kann
aber ich hab noch keinen führerschein
das ist sehr schade ich hätte ihr wie
ich meine vorbildfunktion wahrnehmen ich
habe gesagt weil man was man dann halt
kann so wer versteht schon irgendwie bin
ich dumm weil es eigentlich was gerade
los ist
ich werden können und stick das wäre
schon ganz ganz wird eine ganz feine
sache aber ob es sich lohnt wieder da
hoch zu laufen ich glaube nicht ich
glaube jetzt einfach mal hier unten rum
gucken ob ich da noch ein stück finde
stick wenn ich so stick finde so betone
bevor ich nie geschafft habe ich
wahrscheinlich logistik finden oder
einfach direkt leisen schwer die mine
ist cool
seit wann kriegt man den direkten eisen
schwert in kisten
doch verdammt klicken schon länger ja
ich erinnere mich vielleicht nein ich
weiß nicht ich hatte auch schon mal mit
dem gedanken gespielt aber ich meine
rolle heißt pvp spiele also einfach
red nis ist hier unser do der unser
erstes opfer
ende ich habe schon überlegt ob ich
spiele einfach darum also in der
aufnahme weil ich sonst nie dort einfach
mal umzuschauen auf die leute wirklich
so krass wie sie selbst immer behaupten
umgehen ups oder eben nicht nehmen und
das wäre auf jeden fall interessant
herauszufinden wer der typ ist jetzt ham
aufstauen wien auch was das schon wieder
für namens tom unterstrich pvp
glückwunsch früher war das noch so
immer wenn jemand so ein name hatte dann
konnte man sich verdammt sicher sein
dass ein richtiger besser ist und dass
er eine auseinandernimmt
aber dank den change funktionen haben
all die leute die frau die immer von von
diesen typen jahr kommt wie immer von
diesen leuten zurück wurden hand die
sich auch alle so genannt weil ihr es
respekt vor den namen hatten und jetzt
gibt es viel zu viele leute man kann
einfach das überhaupt nicht mehr nutzen
um irgendwas einzuschätzen denn so mein
freund ins kino textur und lösten mutter
gewünscht übernahme wir können
eigentlich mal so ein video machen
letzte live player nails oder so was
finde ich ganz cool weil es gibt
wirklich so viele vollidioten die sich
irgendwelche behinderten namen geben
und der war nicht mal 06 und hätte ich
den gerade nicht so easy recken können
wo gott ich habe irgendwie gefühl dass
ich kriege es übrigens nicht ernst
gemeint vanicek snowtrex das gerade
sieht weil ich bin gar nicht helfen wird
ich fragte meine letzte mal ob das von
jacko ist er daher handeln alter ich
habe nicht gehackt oder so selbst rennt
einfach instant gegessen habe ich
irgendein back oder so was ich hier die
den zaun bug aber zwar auf jeden fall
verdammt komisch ich habe wirklich
nichts gemacht ich drücke auf enter ich
habe keine hacks auf escape glaubten die
leute haben er schreibt dass ich dumm
bin und hacker ist sowieso ein belanglos
ich glaube ich das irgendwann schon mal
jemand gehackt hat den kanal hat justin
hat ja auch seine seine makro auszusehen
betätigen hat mir erzählt die leute
hätten wie noch wasser umgeleitet
aber warum sollte man seinen ruf mit so
was kaputt machen als youtuber walliser
cvp also was heißt hier
es gibt natürlich leute die schweren
schweren fokus auf pvp hamm als justin
oder ich das jetzt haben aber trotzdem
wenn man so ganz cool ich ein baby warum
sollte man dann mit sechs spielen steht
ihr also doch er versteht es jetzt
verlangt normal
auch das hasse ich an zu weshalb schon
immer gehasst wenn leute nicht daran
hindert teams verboten runde zum glück
weil ich habe bock drauf geachtet wo ich
rein scheine aber
mal sehen aha ich darf nicht mit allen
fans hintergehen jetzt seht ihr es
ausgleich mache jetzt etwas backpulver
langsam esse ich nur für euch gemacht
und lasse meinen ob tief ein blick
schweifen über die landschaft aber das
ist niemand hier herzlich mit mir werden
will und es leben noch so viele leute
ist tom pvp hoffentlich kann ich ihn
besiegen weil der hut vor britta
abstauben und nöten der leaf auf jeden
fall davon in diese richtung wollen wir
mal sehen
also wir haben auch schon fast voller
rüstung mit die schule fehle noch die
guten
also ich weiß gar nicht also tatsächlich
führt man schon ein bisschen dieses
wochenende fahre ich noch mein
geburtstag also nur mit familie kaffee
trinken und so wandert geht es morgen
abend in einen irgendwie ein gutes
restaurant oder sowas wenn dann so ein
bisschen vater sohn michael
was man halt am achtzehnten geburtstag
also jetzt nicht bevor ich denke also
dass wir neben stripclub etwas gebe was
tun wenn ich habe einen sehr anständigen
es erzählt hier gerade irgendjemand
hätte bestimmt gedacht dass wir in step
gehen einfach nur so ein bisschen wie
ski oder so was uns können aber bei
welcher was kann man ja mal machen als
wenn man 18 wird finde ich ja ich habe
ein kompass und jetzt werden apps direkt
isio mein gott so easy rawkins sind
ausgepackt
all diese gefahr und barmusik gedrückt
tvp ii sieger trek team habe bei meinem
anblick mit der kollege ist es ist die
hd
auf eis die wirklichkeit der finnischen
espoo bot er ist sehr high definition
aber könnte ihnen können wir schlagen
er war sehr hd labbadia ihn trotzdem
retten kann
irgendwie bin ich da so richtig auf der
überhaupt provokanten schiene dass ich
mich über alles lustig mache mir leid
jeden fall wenn euch das gestört hat
dann könnt ihr mir kenntnis dass ab ja
genau jetzt en bloc it rains aber jetzt
schlechteres schwert als ich alter
schwede was ist mit solchen menschen los
vergleich seines satz nach schauen
vielleicht ist ja so voll gut
natürlich kann ich trotzdem drücken wäre
wenn es hat so jemand ist ja immer noch
jeden tag es geht sorgt dann sind
natürlich gut aber wer macht sowas schon
aber no na ja er ist sehr nach
informieren
das hat mir auch wirklich mal ich weiß
nicht ob es gab ja schon ein video
gesagt hat man die kommentare
geschrieben du denkst du du bist mit
deinem f5 und rechtsklick trick oder
sowas und das ist einfach nur ein
bisschen so ein kleiner fehler den ich
mache ist das match glaube ich rennen
einfach noch ein bisschen rum
ok der dürfte mich nicht kriegen hoffe
ich jetzt mal verdammt besser gefällt
was heute noch machen soll was zur hölle
konzentriert die auf den anderen daten
fakten dia schwert bruder
aber grad noch so geschafft der kollege
wir laufen im kreis und werden von gäste
verfolgten die boxen sich anscheinend
nicht
ich halte mich so was von zurück von
diesem typen da vorne mit dem t shirt
lasst mich bitte in ruhe meine freunde
und schießt nicht auf mich also die am
rand entlang laufen kann
ob die wirtschaft und zusammen mit mir
gegen diesen die schwer typen kämpfen
vielleicht kann ich wenigstens ihn
retten das wäre schon mal verbrenne ich
also völlig soviel herzen abfackelte
schade
die runde war trotzdem unterhaltsam fand
ich irgendwie nur nein ich finde er muss
nicht mehr machen ist pvp ich wollte
dass er stirbt gutes gestorben mein name
wird entfernt wurde aber naja es war auf
jeden fall auch mal wieder was anderes
sg nach einer ewigkeit mal was anderes
als pet wars und was sie sonst so spiele
ich hoffe dass community cash bald
fertig wird weil ich warte insgeheim
schon ewigkeiten rauch hat es wäre mal
wieder was sich so richtig stolz darauf
wäre euch das zu zeigen ist nämlich echt
ein hammer ding und ja dann schneide ich
das ganze jetzt mal geht zur nachhilfe
und dann ich morgen meinen geburtstag
fällt es irgendwie noch irgendwas plan
irgendwie so ein geburtstag stream oder
sowas ruhig rein sondern lasse ich das
wissen und die abwehr sind zwei mädchen
wieder machtpolitik